money can be hard to come by and Zelda
breath of the wild but if you're
resourceful you can get rich in no time
here are seven tips keep your pockets
full of rupees and subscribe for even
more Zelda tips gather as much stuff as
possible food bugs monster parks you
have a lot of space for resources so
even if you think you might have enough
Picabo and horns take them up anyway you
can sell your extras for a handful of
rupees however consider the fact that
you might need an item later before you
sell it and definitely hold on to
Guardian part one of the best ways to
get rich quickly is to place or in
gemstones if you find a sparkly
Blackrock it contains some sort of or we
can blow it up with a bomb but that
might make the valuable stones inside go
flying out of reach so the safer method
is to hit the rock with a sledgehammer
or other very sturdy weapon so I'll jump
them to any merchant for a large sum of
rupees a fine meal can fetch a pretty
nice price if you have a dish you don't
really need maybe you made one that
restores more hearts than you even have
available sell it you'll often get more
rupees than if you had sold the
ingredients on their own
while traveling in the forest of breath
of the wild you might encounter a
glowing blue rabbit it'll run away if
you get too close but if you crouch and
get close enough to hit it with an arrow
it will drop a random amount of receive
if an NPC has a red exclamation point
icon when they talk to you they have a
sidequest offer they vary from gathering
items to completing tasks and more and
you can often earn 20 to 100 rupees
pretty easily when in doubt try a Zelda
amiibo you can enable amiibo use in the
game options which will add the ability
to your room tapping an amiibo on the
right joint Kahn's NFC reader will drop
items depending on the amiibo so you
might get something good to sell or even
just some rupees the most obvious way to
get rich is to look for treasure chests
they can be found all over and often
contain something valuable like a
gemstone other times they'll contain
rupees themselves harder to find
treasure chests generally have more
valuable loot inside of course money
isn't everything and there's plenty more
to do in breadth of the wild be sure to
check out our tips for making the most
of cooking and 9 things the game doesn't
tell you Oh
[Music]